On September 4, 2020,
the Centers for Disease Control
halted residential evictions
in the United States
for nonpayment of rent,
because of the COVID19 pandemic.
Eviction protection still needs
to be the very top priority.
Forcing thousands of
people out of their homes
during a pandemic will make
a public health crisis worse.
Many states and municipalities
got there first,
imposing at least partial
eviction moratorium
starting in March and April.
The theory behind these emergency orders
was that if Americans were
forced to leave their homes
and move into more crowded settings,
it would increase transmission
of the coronavirus.
The federal ban was supposed
to expire at the end of 2020.
Then it was extended a
month, then two more months,
then three more months
and then until the end of July.
Many states and cities
have also extended their moratoriums,
in some cases through
the end of September,
even as COVID infection and
death rates are plummeting.
That's gonna make matters
even worse for landlords.
The smaller mom and pop landlords
who depend the most on rent
for their personal income
are being hardest hit
by renters not paying.
Tenants will end up picking up the tab.
I pay it.
I have to raise rents to cover
the eight or nine tenants
who aren't paying that I have.
Small landlord, who make up the majority
of rental property owners in America
have been forced to raise rents,
remove units from the housing market,
or refuse law income or
credit impaired tenants.
Fair laws for landlords.
Were the eviction bans necessary
to protect public health
during the pandemic?
Two studies that got
widespread media attention,
and that have also been cited
by the Federal Government
to support its policies,
claim to show that the moratoriums
saved thousands of lives.
These studies that have
been widely publicized
are seriously flawed.
The underlying data
inconsistent and incomplete.
The results are implausible.
The size of the effect is
wildly disproportionate
to other public health interventions.
And the researchers claim an
absurd amount of certainty
despite the fact that the underlying data
are highly uncertain.
Aaron Brown is a statistician
who has taught at NYU and UCSD.
He's also the former Chief Risk Officer
at the hedge fund, AQR Capital Management.
If these studies are correct,
they should be in big, bold headlines
of every newspaper in America.
They would be the most
dramatic public health finding
in history.
One study from Duke University researchers
found that compared to a scenario
without any eviction moratoriums,
policies that limit evictions
could have reduced COVID19
infections by 14.2%
and deaths by 40.7%.
The second study, whose lead author
is a postdoctoral researcher at UCLA,
found that in states
that had eviction bans
but lifted them before the
CDC moratorium kicked in,
there were between 8,988
and 12,470 excess deaths
caused by lifting the moratoriums.
To have the CDC come out
in the context of the pandemic
and say that this was their rationale
for the moratorium was really powerful.
Brown says the first
problem with these studies
is that they draw strong
conclusions from poor data.
Information on where, when,
and how many evictions occur
in the US is collected by a patchwork
of local governments and courts,
and is notoriously
inaccurate and incomplete.
The important question
for public policy is,
if we have eviction moratorium,
will it reduce COVID deaths?
In order to establish a
causal link of that sort,
you'd gotta work through it step by step.
How do the eviction
moratorium affect evictions?
How do evictions affected crowding?
How does crowding affect
virus transmission?
How does virus transmission
affect infections and deaths?
The researchers don't even try to do this.
And they can't because
we don't have the data
in each of those links.
Brown says the studies' final numbers
are particularly implausible
when compared to other
public health interventions.
The Duke study, for example,
claims that had the
federal eviction moratorium
been in place between
March and November of 2020,
about 40 percent of all
Americans who died from COVID19
in that period would have been spared.
In other words, about 122,000
lives would have been saved
compared to a scenario
with no moratoriums at all.
To put that into context,
the CDC estimates that 600,000 Americans
have died from COVID19 in total.
The moratoriums
might have prevented tens
of thousands of evictions.
Even if we ignore the offsetting effect
of people moving into the vacated housing
and reducing crowding,
the eviction moratorium
might have reduce the COVID infection
by a few hundred people.
Even allowing for a super spreader event,
it's unlikely that the
evictees would have caused
more than a few thousand
additional infection
in the population.
Using the casemortality
ratios at the time,
gives us a number of
approximately a hundred deaths
that might have been prevented
by eviction moratorium.
But the researchers claim high confidence
for thousands or tens of
thousands of lives save,
that's just implausible.
Statistical studies not
only present findings,
they also include what's
known as confidence intervals
to express the level of certainty
we should have in the results.
In both studies, the
authors' claim 95% confidence
in their final conclusions.
The most precise data both studies use
is the number of COVID deaths.
And serious researchers
disagree about that
by a factor of 60%.
The studies rely on long chains of data,
each link of which has much
greater uncertainty than 60%,
And the final uncertainty,
their answer has to be the product
of all of the individual uncertainties.
Yet, these research claim
they can evaluate the causal
effect of eviction moratorium
with standard errors
of roughly 10% or 20%.
And they have 95% confidence
in those estimates.
Angela] Admitting county's band evictions,
now researchers from
Duke say those places,
they're seeing fewer cases
and deaths due to COVID19.
The Duke study was coauthored
by a team of academics with
prestigious credentials,
including a professor of economics
with a PhD from Stanford,
and a quantitative epidemiologist
and assistant professor of Medicine.
In the study, which was published
in the National Bureau
of Economic Researchers'
Working Paper series,
the authors didn't include the datasets
they had used to reach their conclusions.
And listed just two of
their sources of data.
So, Reason contacted the authors
and asked to see their math.
As the US Department of
Health and Human Services
Office of Research Integrity states,
"Once a researcher has published
the results of an experiment,
it is generally expected
that all the information
about that experiment,
including the final data,
should be freely available
for other researchers
to check and use."
These guidelines apply to
federally funded studies,
but are standard practice
among academic researchers.
But Duke University denied our request
on the grounds that the study
hasn't been peer-reviewed,
and therefore wasn't
considered published work.
The Duke paper is what's
known as a pre-print,
in which researchers make
a study publicly available
prior to submitting it
to an academic journal.
And yet the authors gave interviews
in which they promoted their findings.
And the paper was widely
cited in the press,
appears twice in the Federal Register
as part of rule-making issued
by the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau,
and was cited in an amicus brief
at the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
to support legal arguments
that eviction moratoriums
have spared COVID19 deaths.
Duke also trumpeted the
findings in a press release
that encouraged members
of the media interested
in speaking with the
authors to get in touch.
Though apparently not
if that meant scrutinizing
the actual dataset
or code used to generate
the paper's claims.
The Duke researchers only cite sources
for the two of the data elements they use
and those citations incomplete.
They claim to have gotten
county-level death data
from the COVID Tracking
Project, but that project
doesn't have county level data at all.
The Duke researchers also won't tell us
when they accessed the data,
or how they matched it up with other data.
If someone says they ran
a multivariate regression,
you wanna know the exact code
and adjustments they made.
This the only way independent researchers
can validate the findings.
Even without access
to the researchers' data or code,
Brown was able to
discern a variety of ways
in which the study misuses
statistical techniques
to arrive at faulty conclusions.
First, the authors look only
at differences within states,
when one locality had an
eviction moratorium in place
and another didn't.
But they don't compare the
COVID rates in entire states
that had an eviction moratorium
with those that didn't.
Brown says it's clear
that at the state level,
those with moratoriums
actually experienced
more COVID deaths than
states without them.
The orange line shows states
that always had an eviction
moratorium in place.
The black line represents states
that never banned evictions.
This finding, like the Duke study,
is a correlation and almost
certainly not causal.
It doesn't prove that eviction moratoriums
cause death.
What it does do is put the burden of proof
on anyone claiming a
dramatic health benefit
from eviction moratoriums to
explain why it doesn't show up
in the aggregate data.
In fact, why we see the opposite.
The Duke study is arguing
that eviction moratoriums
caused COVID deaths rate to
decline, and dramatically.
If that were true, we should
see the effect at all levels,
both within the states and between states.
But the latter data doesn't support
the authors' conclusions,
so they ignored it.
The authors also ignore the timing
of when people died from COVID19.
After states lifted their moratoriums,
they had the same death rates
as states that kept their bans in place.
And places that had moratoriums
saw a major increase in COVID
deaths in the summer of 2020.
While in places that
never banned evictions,
death rates remained low.
The other big data
problems for the authors
is that COVID death rates were higher
when eviction moratorium were in place
than when they weren't.
They don't make the obvious
comparison of one place
when it had an eviction
moratorium versus when it didn't.
All they do is they compare
two different places,
one of which had an eviction moratorium
and one of which didn't.
These two statistical manipulations
allow the authors to get rid
of the obvious objections to their study.
All we can say is we have
no idea from the data
whether there's any causal
effect, one way or the other.
That eviction moratorium
increase COVID death rates,
decrease them, or have no affect at all.
We don't know.
A new UCLA paper out this week,
directly links evictions
to the spread of COVID19.
The study is awaiting peer review
but we wanted to make
sure that policy makers
have these numbers in hand
as they're making decision.
Another widely cited study,
which also hasn't been peer-reviewed
or appeared in an academic journal,
looks at a period in which
the CDC eviction moratorium
wasn't in place, during which
evictions were partly allowed
in 27 states.
It argues that there were
between 8,988 and 12,470
excess deaths caused by
evictions in those states
during this period.
It also claims a 95% confidence
interval for that finding.
This study,
written by an interdisciplinary
team of researchers
from several premier
American universities,
was cited by the CDC
in its March 31st order
extending the federal eviction moratorium.
Like the Duke study, it was
cited in the Federal Register
and in the amicus brief
to the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals.
The study's lead author,
postdoctoral researcher Kathryn Leifheit
of the UCLA Fielding
School of Public Health,
promoted the paper's conclusions
in interviews with NPR, Vox,
CNBC, ABC, and other outlets.
Whenever you see numbers
like 430,000 cases,
10,000 deaths, these are
deaths that could have been
prevented had the states
maintained their moratoriums.
It really is a human tragedy
and not just numbers.
But when Reason reached out to her
for an interview and said we were working
with a statistician to
examine the underlying data,
she didn't reply to our query.
This study is a model of transparent,
scientific reporting.
The authors tells you exactly
where they got their data
and exactly what they did with it.
I can duplicate their study.
That also means I can pinpoint
exactly what they did wrong.
This study gets around the problem
of the shoddy data on evictions
by comparing death rates
at times when moratoriums
were in force versus times
when they were not in force.
Like the Duke study,
it's looking to tease out
the effect of a policy
through correlation.
The researchers note in some places
when eviction moratoriums were listed,
COVID death rates went up.
But they don't tell you is in most places,
the opposite happened.
And in the aggregate,
More than half the study's
total of extra deaths,
they attribute to lifting
eviction moratoriums
come from Texas and South Carolina.
If this were a genuine causal effect,
you expect to see it in every state
or at least in most states.
And you'd expect to see it
when the federal eviction ban
were put in place.
The fact that the authors
can find a strong effect
in only two out of 50 states,
says that this cannot
possibly be a causal effect.
Further complicating the study's results,
while it's true that in
South Carolina and Texas
there were no statewide
eviction moratoriums
during the study period,
major cities and counties within
Texas had some type of ban.
And in South Carolina,
the State Supreme Court
ordered strong restrictions
on eviction statewide.
And nationwide, many jurisdictions
that didn't have explicit moratoriums
still effectively halted
evictions for months at a time
as courts were shut down by
social distancing directives.
Others layered on emergency
tenant protections,
subsidized housing costs, or
abated eviction proceedings
for a period of weeks to months.
All of these places are counted
as having no eviction moratorium at all.
When Brown adjusts the authors' analysis
to account for local moratoriums
and effective bans on eviction.
The authors' effect goes away.
Whether or not they did so knowingly,
Brown says the authors ended
up manipulating the data
to produce results that
don't pass the sniff test.
The elephant in the room
is the last couple of decades
have seen floods of misconduct
including fraudulent data,
no data, and radically
misrepresented data.
We see it at the top
institutions, the top researchers,
top scientists.
And the most discouraging part
is institutions and journals
circle the wagons to protect wrongdoers
and slander anyone who
questions the results.
Duke had one of the most expensive
and prominent examples of this.
When over a decade, the University
protected a medical researcher
publishing false medical data.
The University promised
this would not happen again.
But the next chance they got,
when researchers were promoting
dramatic public health claims
but refusing to release the data,
the University closed ranks.
While at the same time,
pushing the findings out
to any gullible reporters or
policymakers they can find
The document Kathryn Leifheit
has compiled is deaths.
There are states, percentages,
graphs, and numbers.
Lots of numbers.
The study is still in pre-print.
That means it has not
been peer-reviewed yet.
Normally, we wouldn't
cover a study like that.
Thanks to journalist like you,
it is getting a fair amount of attention.
Cancel the rent.
Tell that landlord he don't get a cent.
"Cancel the Rent" activists
may have other reasons for wanting
to make eviction bans permanent,
but they've seized on the results
from these studies to pressure lawmakers
and to push for a large expansion
of the Federal Government's
role in the housing market.
An eviction crisis is looming.
The moratorium is about to expire.
Millions will be faced with
eviction unless Congress acts.
I'm hearing numbers as
many as 30 million people
could be affected.
Is that right?
So that's one number
that's been cited for sure.
To the extent we're going to involve
scientific researchers
in policy discussions,
we should focus on the issues
that have been studied by
many people, validated,
sharing data, argued back and forth.
These shoddy one-off
studies are just ammunition
for people who want to put a
link saying "studies prove"
in an otherwise purely
speculative article.